Dog.
I had an old parable about a month ago.
I found the back of my draw.
That thing,
fuck me up 12 hours.
That's like an expired viking and you would take an expired viking.
You won't have paid for a week.
Mouth.
I don't care how many root canals they give you.
Broad.
Tom Looks fired.
Biking with my pants,
my wife and watch that tape had a viking.
I popped that motherfucking after it was wash.
Oh,
I'm going to have a job
fucking bleach on it.
I just found it.
I found it even on the vikings.
I took one hour,
he caves.
I had to pay and those pain,
I never wore those pants again.
I go to porn and I go on the pants and that Ar,
she washed it right before I went on stage.
I pop that up.
That motherfucker
who gives a fuck.
I don't even know what is the more I've been through everything.
One fucking pulling.
I do that dog.
Oh,
how strong was it?
Oh my God.
I picked a half on stage and I blacked out like the first 30 minutes.
I couldn't wait to get back to the hotel room,
feet.
The other.